[Music]
okay we're gonna play that that game
again we're gonna look at about two ball
game yeah we're on the medicine ball oh
I thought were just getting [ __ ] yes
is it more than last time
no this is usual jury you're right okay
yeah right
our jackoff massage place is essential I
would say so in Japan I would argue that
because you know for people that can't
jack off
they have jack off artists go to their
house artists yeah I called him artist
some people call him hookers I call them
angels Tudor was that there was a club
it's like a gay club with a glory hole
that was declared an official business
it was an American Florida I don't know
where exactly sounds like a Utah kind of
thing I always Lori walls like who's
behind the wall and who's in maybe a gay
guy whoever do what needs to be that's
the fun part whatever God wants you to
are you the one going in front of the
hole or are you the one behind it prints
on what side from the pornos I've seen
yeah a man goes into a like al annoyed
they're always in the back of like porn
like stores and then there's like a
secret room back there and then the guy
is always like you know and then the and
then the guy puts his dick through the
hole and there's like a lady there my
understanding is that there's always
extremely beautiful women behind me I
just dared that it might be somebody
that's desperate for money like
somebody's uncle oh you know the
sweetest thing that movie and then like
how there was a guy behind it sticking
his dick through the hole so it's like
are people going up to the hole cuz they
want to dick in their mouth I think so
yeah anyway what do you think is
happening here definitely not a glory
the glory hole is all through this thing
are they building bridges to bridge to
the game aid cities they meet a giant
staples it looks like a train bridge or
something a train bridge yeah it looks
like a bridge solar panels solar panel
actually like a kid's toy set that they
just framed it to look real oh I think
you're really warm what some kids
[ __ ] model maybe oh you're kidding
so far from me I'm kidding
oh it just looks like I felt life or
lover finally making eel on some [ __ ]
monorail thingy the hyper that's the
shortest [ __ ]
oh I see this I think this is an Egypt
or something it is this is in Cairo so
apparently the city greenlit this
[ __ ] bridge inch away from the
[ __ ] apartment centimetres away from
these buildings hey I had a window can
you can you imagine being this
[ __ ] right here like it's just
completely blah yeah that's my window
come on
I see it lighted here just wait till
those cars there wait till someone
crashes crashed into the living room
alright so the story here like I said
dude that's funny man that's so funny
that their dad to it okay something like
their 50 centimeters away this is proof
that the Egyptians there now aren't the
same ones who built the pyramids they're
not the slaves well really still
counting like that 50 centimeters no
it's not you lost count this is a
centimeter a centimeter is like like the
Venge
oh that's an inch yeah 0:07 leaders like
this no oh you mean all you mean the
width that like that top to bottom but
yeah yeah yeah yeah I was counting 1 2 3
4 5 yeah probably
anyway how you know if your fingers not
going back down though your
yeah I like this one two three four five
six seven eight yeah that's the bottom
one yeah I know
I gotta do it on the desk okay yeah yeah
yeah okay do it why do we need this unit
how about that question we figure out
the fact the world uses it yes Dean
that's about this much about he did well
I think we can try to measure something
with your articles and you're like yes
we like this show does with information
we're like here's the information you
know something like that
well anyways so they okay so the
authorities in Cairo have come under
fire for approving the construction of
this essential highway and so they're
saying that the residents of these
buildings have been protesting for years
to not build this but they still went
ahead to [ __ ] you actually and they
actually said the authorities of the
city whatever they actually said
actually you're residential buildings
were built without the proper permit so
you guys are the ones that have to get
out of here to make room for this
highway you're the Karen's we're not the
Karen's you're the Karen dam and the
whole thing was written hieroglyphics
exactly bird bird opium [ __ ] Farrow
whipping somebody on a cherry pot I know
waves a supplier I know a team of eight
slaves a guy with a bird on his head
no [ __ ] dog man someone's like this
before they are saying that they will
need to demolish these apartment
building there whatever we know you guys
don't like I guess good news to this
story is that they will receive a
portion of the 250 million Egyptian
pounds which comes out to about fifteen
point eight million dollars allocated to
compensate the residents of those
buildings probably back enough for all
those buildings damn so they're gonna
build a new highway dollars and then pay
the people whose houses they're tearing
down because it's too close to the
highway yep Wow
well I mean they could have just moved
them out first and then built everything
a lot more space to build to the
construction we take we also technically
have the same thing here where they can
they can seize your property if it's for
government buildings or mail post
offices issue they have done every way
they tore down a shit-ton of home
man from well but I guess the order is
oh yeah but I guess the order is where
they [ __ ] up oh I usually lay
everything out and then they build it
but we got some half built ass highways
here that's been sitting for like over
20 years and [ __ ] [ __ ] you right dude
how come during Corona they didn't fix
the road but then when we're all busy as
[ __ ] rousting been like this everyone is
everyone now like [ __ ] jam pack on
the freeway let's start yeah that's the
perfect time to fix the 405 everything
everything city workers out like in my
city they're cutting the trees they're
doing all kinds of lectric 'el work I
saw him fixing the 134 I'm like this is
the smallest freeway in America the one
that doesn't need work actually that
one's got a nice road it's great yeah
sure one thing where's that it's the
Glendale one yeah it's great Racing's
you know which was a really really
really curvy 101 110 that one it goes
well the 110 but it meets yeah then it
meets the 101 but make sure to get all
the 101 south I had no idea this was an
LA thing you guys we see the Saturday
Live skit called the Californians and
the whole thing is them being like oh
man got on the 110 to the 7 to the 405
oh man it was so good and that's a whole
conversation I could literally have a
30-minute conversation on just traffic
in which freeways you should have taken
and all that yeah but we don't have that
no more with the road has no chance
because I'm old
I wished but it has been getting a
little people going back to work yeah
just a little bit now that we're on
stage too even coming here I was like Oh
hit a little little bit of a little bit
of this don't you wish that it was
always like this in LA and people just
stayed home and didn't do anything I've
actually been thinking about it I'm like
I wonder if we will have significantly
less traffic because a lot of people
have realized oh [ __ ] I can't actually
do a lot of my work from home hopefully
there'll be a lot less it's necessary
because this place is gonna be not you
don't be able to live here in ten years
if it keeps going at the rate it was
going we maxed out on how much housing
it is available for people that's why
the real estate is so damn expensive and
then they just recently allowed
sectioning off the homes so you could
have a single resident right yeah you
could half the house could do you could
duplex a regular single-family residence
and that wasn't like yeah I wasn't it
was really hard to get it it was really
hard or some people just had to do it
illegally
Paul said I was legal back then but now
like it's people are converting their
garage to being like what do you call it
like a grandma's nest or something oh ma
[Laughter]
I definitely understood what you're
saying like what the Egyptians did with
yeah I wonder their legal documents is
still from the ancient times and [ __ ] no
okay muttering a [ __ ] tablet into
court yeah a piece of rock yeah it's a
rock what a [ __ ] time joke but like
you know you don't see a whole lot of
pictures of Egypt aside from the
pyramids right so the first time I saw a
picture of the pyramids but the
perspective where it's like well it's
our last like you know things it's like
downtown in the background of the piers
what's like Las Vegas oh [ __ ] yeah like
when you looking at the luck scored big
that's [ __ ] ridiculous what it's real
and the mummies are watching you got me
back because I thought Egyptian people
were like sometimes they have bird heads
a dog head
right sphynx isn't she really elongated
yeah too much eyeliner the noses were
broken off yeah look that's a nice robe
you got on today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]